in uvalde texas an unbearable final
goodbye to so many young victims
so many funerals
so much pain for one small town to
comprehend
this and so many more beyond prompted a
prime time presidential address
joe biden flanked down the white house
corridor by a candle for each of the 56
states and territories of this nation
because this gun violence has touched
every corner
for god's sake
how much more carnage are we willing to
accept
how many more innocent american lives
must be taken before we say enough
enough
this year alone there have been
234 mass shootings in america that's 10
a week this among the latest a hospital
in tulsa oklahoma two doctors a patient
and a receptionist dead
shot by a man who bought his
semi-automatic weapon just hours earlier
we need to ban assault weapons in
high-capacity magazines
and if we can't ban assault weapons then
we should raise the aids to purchase
them from 18 to 21.
in uvalde on sunday he felt the pain of
19 sets of parents and the survivors
imagine being that little girl that
brave little girl in uvalde
who smeared blood off her murdered
friend's body on her own face
to lie still among the corpses in her
classroom and pretend she was dead in
order to stay alive
it was a presidential appeal from the
executive in the white house to the
legislators here on capitol hill the
message this time do something and they
will discuss gun control next week but
don't expect any radical change while
the majority of americans do want to see
changes on gun control the politics of
it is paralyzed
and so divided too listen to the
politicians at the heart of the debate
it doesn't fit so this gun would be
banned i hope this gun is not loaded
i'm at my house i can do whatever i want
with my gun for america the reality is
that it is so much more complicated than
simply banning some weapons
guns are as much a symbolic issue in
this country as they are a real issue
and symbols in politics are very
powerful
potent weapons themselves
the calls for change come every time and
yet this uniquely american cycle of gun
violence goes on and on mark stone sky
news in washington